- Did you know that roughly
four out of 10 marriages
end in divorce?
- I mean, I get it.
- That number has come down
somewhat since the 1980s, but.
(record scratches)
Wait, what do you mean you get it?
- Oh, just the things
don't always work out
the way you envision.
- Go on.
- Well, for example, I was
fairly certain when I was little
that my husband would be-
- Yes?
- Jonathan Taylor Thomas.
But I'm glad he's not.
This is so much better.
- For one reason or another-
- I'm pretty sure.
- For one reason or another,
lots of marriages simply run their course,
and finding yourself suddenly single
is a major life change
that can turn your finances upside down.
- When it comes to untangling your money
and starting over, what
happens to your debt?
How are your assets divided?
How do your taxes change,
and what does it all mean for your income?
- Jonathan Taylor Thomas.
(uplifting music)
- Divorce can be a wealth strangler.
If you hire a divorce attorney
to handle all the nuts
and bolts, you could easily drop tens
of thousands of dollars on legal fees.
Attorneys do a lot,
like negotiating with your
spouse's lawyer on your behalf,
drawing up paperwork and correctly filing
so all of your divorce is
legal in the eyes of the law.
- You'll probably keep more money
in your pocket going through mediation.
This involves hiring a neutral third party
who is specially trained in divorce law
and dispute resolution to
help you work out the details
of the split.
Mediation is typically faster, cheaper,
and less stressful,
though it may entail
hiring some other experts
like an appraiser to value your property,
a social worker to weigh in
on child custody questions,
and perhaps even a lawyer
since mediators cannot give legal advice.
Mediation can be a solid option
if you have a straightforward
divorce where both parties
are in agreement on most things.
But if you're butting
heads and things drag on,
the final bill can get hefty.
- Divorce could throw
a lower earning spouse
into financially choppy waters, especially
if they've been a stay at home parent.
All of a sudden they're on
their own to manage their money
and keep up their household
as a single person.
Think of alimony, aka spousal support,
as a temporary lifeline,
one spouse provides financial support
for a predetermined amount of time
so that other can catch their breath.
Every state has its own rules
for determining alimony,
but both parties' income
and expenses usually come into play.
The idea is to enable
the lower earning spouse
to maintain a similar standard
of living post divorce.
- Raising kids comes with
a lot of expenses too.
There's food, clothing,
housing, healthcare, activities,
and so much more.
Child support swoops in to make sure
that each parent continues
paying their fair share
after the divorce.
Each state has its own guidelines
for calculating it, but
certain factors tend
to carry the most weight,
namely your income, your ex's income,
the number of children you have,
their unique needs and
your custody arrangement.
It's usually structured as a
monthly payment that fades out
as each child comes of age.
- Chances are going from
a two income household
to the single life is going
to affect your lifestyle.
If you own a home with your soon to be ex,
you'll have to figure out
what to do with your digs.
A property appraisal
can clarify the numbers.
One of you could buy the
other out either with cash
or by giving up other assets,
like investments or retirement accounts.
The one keeping the property
would then refinance
the mortgage into their name,
or you might agree to sell the property
and split the profit 50/50
before going your separate ways.
- How you split up your debt depends a lot
on what state you live in.
In some, a judge may decide
to use their own discretion
to break up your debt based
on factors like income,
employment and who accumulated it.
In other states,
marital debt is simply split
down the middle, and that's that.
- Let's say you've each
got some student debt
and credit cards, but one
spouse has way more debt
than the other.
Unless you can agree
on how to split it up,
you'll have to go to the court
and let the judge decide
based on state laws.
- The IRS doesn't care if
you're married or divorced,
they just wanna get paid.
During tax time,
you'll likely go from filing
jointly to doing it solo,
sounds easy enough, but
things can get sticky
the year you get divorced.
Married couples benefit
from certain tax breaks
so your accountant might
actually suggest filing jointly
if you're separated but not yet divorced.
- When you do start filing
your taxes separately
and you've got kiddos, you
guys will have to figure out
who's claiming them as dependents.
It's important because
it could open the door
for some nice tax credits.
- One other thing, alimony
and child support don't count
as taxable income.
Good news for the receiving spouse,
but the spouse making these payments
can't write it off as
a tax deduction either.
Sorry, but that's the rule as of 2019.
- Yikes, this stuff is
kind of a downer, huh?
- Yeah, but it can also
be a teachable moment
for couples who want to turn things around
and grow together.
- Couple's therapy can be a game changer.
Think of it as routine maintenance
to help keep your
relationship going strong.
We've been going for 13 years,
and it's made all the difference.
- Or you might find that
you'd be truly happier
starting a new chapter on your own.
Maybe you'll meet somebody new
and better like Jonathan Taylor Thomas
- Save it for therapy.
- And that's our "Two Cents".
- Thanks to our patrons
for keeping "Two Cents"
financially healthy.
Click the link
in the description to
become a "Two Cents" patron.
- What is Jonathan Taylor
Thomas doing in 2022?
Jonathan Taylor Thomas is living his life,
walking his dogs and being happy.